no idea did you hear that
are they able to hear that
Taylor Swift's piano malfunctions on
stage I would always like to keep people
on their toes it all went down night
three of Tay's airs tour in Foxborough
Massachusetts at one point her piano
started playing on its own do you guys
hear your coach
back
without I'm not touching that you have
no idea did you hear that
are they able to hear that
I didn't play that so that means that
yeah it totally seems haunted
[Music]
well that's not exactly the case Taylor
explained to the crowd how the rainstorm
on night two of our Foxborough shows
could be to blame so it rained a lot
last night
um to the exact it rained for
um three and a half hours straight and
it just kept getting more and more rain
literally it was like a water park under
the stage you know when you've been in a
bath for too long and your fingers are
so pruned that it's like like I looked
at my fingers trying to like fret and
play guitar these are things that make
me break out in a full body sweat but
Tay didn't sweat it and shook things off
continuing her set on the guitar it's
just unbelievable and turns out that
stormy night was very special to her in
a pose she wrote that she and her
swifties danced together in the rain for
the entire three and a half hours quote
we've had rain shows at Gillette Stadium
before but this was a full-on deluge
that never let up I just want to thank
that iconic crowd love you so much you
have no idea I just to have a great time
with these things at the same show
Taylor also expressed how she feels
about her life I've just never been
anything this happy in my life in all
aspects of my life ever
and I just want to thank you for being a
part of that like you know
it's not just a tour this all comes amid
her romance with Maddie Healy who she's
been hanging out with since May you
never know what it's gonna be earlier
this month a sourceful E.T Taylor has a
crush on the musician and Matt thinks
Taylor is awesome and Incredibly
talented he was even recently spotted
dancing and singing at her Nashville
concert
[Applause]
[Music]
that's so good another source tells E.T
in the days leading up to her
Massachusetts show Taylor spent time at
a New York Studio where Maddie joined
her once staying until after 2 A.M
[Music]
like nothing's going rain on Taylor's
parade not even a malfunctioning piano
did you hear that
the piano are they able to hear that